[Music]
confined spaces present a very material
problem for Japanese architects which
they often resolved using ethereal
solutions like the innovative
manipulation of light few sites in Tokyo
better demonstrate how sunlight can make
a small home seem larger than the plump
and aptly named penguin house it was
designed by award-winning architect
Yasuhiro Yamashita whose design
philosophy revolves around the notion of
allowing the structures environment to
dictate the architectural approach
located on a corner lot in Tokyo Zita
Bashi district penguin house is small
even by Tokyo standards the structures
footprint takes up a mere 322 square
feet the size of a two-car garage the
houses floor space covers just 899
square feet you mush it a used light to
make the cramped interior seem more
expansive Sango Gardena the door oh God
there here is the passageway yeah Quenya
the street is here and the land is here
they're using a very simple idea I set
up four walls and cut off the corners
light comes inside through these cut out
corners and these cut off corners are
all illuminated
and by placing a glass box on top of it
I've realized a space where the light
comes in and you can see outside oh yeah
I messed up but deft use of light was
just the point of departure for this
veteran architect Yamashita has also
made rooms feel bigger by extending
sight lines the streamlined design of
the staircase affords occupants of view
past the stairs to the open space beyond
also this kitchen countertop floats
above the stairwell using space that is
usually wasted and with no visible
support structure creating a less
cluttered appearance the openness of the
space in penguin house is truly an
illusion none of these rooms is larger
than 200 square feet
gingka lucky the entrance hall is narrow
but has a high ceiling and welcomes
people with the sense of open space
above them Nick Kolkata tecum and here
in this corner is a small bathroom the
area itself is small but because the
ceiling is high it does not feel very
small Simek and human beings do not find
the area small if the area has a high
ceiling and we use this logic in various
ways you don't not be in photoscape tree
Yamashita raised and lowered ceiling
heights throughout the house depending
on the floor space of the room
the smaller the room the higher the
ceiling the 21 foot tall foyer sits next
to a music studio with a nine foot high
ceiling on the second floor the 11 foot
tall bathrooms are joined the lower 8
foot tall bedroom light height and sight
nowhere in the house do these attributes
make small seem larger than in the
top-level bounded by wall-to-wall
windows the coral penguin house upon
this penguin house we made this room on
the third floor
into a light box light comes in and
disperses and you can see outside which
gives you the sense of space and in that
sense this glass box provides you with a
feeling of roominess good enough
[Music]